my question is this what advice can you
give for instance to our Minister of
Education but also of the ministers of
culture in our European community to
change this very dangerous situation I
think first of all I have to compliment
you I think this is it was a very clear
diagnosis of the problem but I think you
have the wrong doctor in mind I can
think you have to go to the Ministry of
Culture you have to go to the minister
education and so that in the schools you
learn about these things but it will not
happen it's not happening it's not
happening but this you know there are
many aspects it's not a question of is
it important you know and in what way is
it important it's also the fact that the
human being is an animal that needs
variety but also needs familiarity and
if you are familiar with music if you
listen to music when you are very young
when you are a child then you get used
to it it's very difficult this is the
same problem of contemporary music why
is it that music that has been written a
hundred years ago I just conducted last
week a whole cycle of with works of
Schomburg in London and in Paris and you
should have seen oh the things that
people said and they were very happy
ending but they talked about this was a
great adventure in modern music most of
the pieces
between 1908 and 1928 so what why is it
why is Schomburg still inaccessible
why is Schaumburg still thought of as
modern music because it was never part
of the regular reporter of the
orchestra's therefore the musicians
themselves don't have the necessary
familiarity to eat with it as they do
with the works that were written only 30
or 40 years earlier like the symphonies
of Brahms do you know you never see a
musician in the first-class orchestra
who has a few bars rest counting the
beats in a 1 to 2 and then play in a
Brahms Symphony because they know the
pieces they are familiar with it they
are familiar not only with their part
but what everybody else is playing but
with the shorter pieces you know when do
I come in
and therefore familiarity is not there
already in the performance and on top of
it is played very rarely this is why it
is it's vicious circle this is the
played souls seldom therefore they learn
it in order to play it on this
particular Thursday of this week and
they don't play for another 17 years and
of course the next time is probably
somebody else and if it's the same
person he's already forgotten it and
therefore the audience also doesn't get
the familiarity because it that it
doesn't hear it often enough but
familiarity is a very important aspect
of enjoyment and in the attitude of
wanting to do something or experience
something in life and this is why there
is no shortcut that you really if you
want people to go to the concert hall or
to the Opera House's when they are 25
and with the 30 instead of starting to
go at 45 you have to really make them
used to hearing music and being familiar
not only with the pieces but with the
act of listening to music already from a
very early age you know I got into a lot
of trouble one day when I was music
director in Chicago
and I was going ask to go for dinner
with some potential contributors sort of
fundraising so I went very nice people
and they ask me something similar to
what used to what you just said no and I
said to them I said look I said you have
to just imagine a child being born
somewhere in Chicago doesn't matter if
it sits in a rich Knight neighborhood or
no poor a child being born somewhere in
Chicago no music at home nor music is
being played nobody sings nothing he
doesn't the child doesn't hear any music
at all then it goes to kindergarten no
music whatsoever then he goes to school
he studies he's a good student
no music never heard anything never
finished his school with quite good
notes goes to good university in America
and comes back and becomes a lawyer or a
doctor in Chicago and he marries a
beautiful American blonde and they have
two lovely children and now he is 28 29
32 and he is considered one of the best
lawyers and doctors in Chicago and he
goes to dinner with some friends and I
said to them to this restaurant for the
lovely restaurant it was a wonderful
restaurant and then somebody says to him
do you ever go to the Chicago Symphony
Orchestra and he says Chicago Symphony
what is that they said Chicago Symphony
Orchestra is an orchestra it is the best
orchestra in the world you know there's
nothing like it in the world the best
orchestra of the world
you should go you'll love it and it will
be good for you to be seen there and
this very famous doctor a lawyer of 32
comes the next week to the Chicago
Symphony and here's me conductor
Schoenberg variations for Orchestra
what can he get out of it
and we didn't get any money from them
obviously